[Music]
all right can you see the form with
ethnic people that wanted to win that
partial licenses we have six of them so
we did a stupid but working solution do
random basically I know that some people
had to run for their yeah had to run for
the for the trains and all the planes
and stuff like that so we'll send every
license code to them by email but we
have first winner as : 11 dosti I'll
make a note on that
Clara here our second winner Tom alpha
by Stefan user footage we have used the
same way to to find a winners of many of
the biases we had for our Meetup and
sometimes this this way of drawing like
guys it's gonna bring different very
funny results I don't remember one of
the draw we had like for 300 people on
the list and random gave us first
strange results from the middle to come
and recap our MTAC so we have 5 we have
500 last one sylvester Binkowski so
these are the lucky ones will probably
send you the email a big early next to
you next week when we have some rest
after the conference ok and this is
basically what we have preferred for you
for for these two days I hope you
enjoyed that I want to face a huge thank
you for the organising committee and for
the program committee so those from the
organising committee and program can you
please stand up and go to the stage I
don't want to see you who you are in
person Martha
[Applause]
okay unfortunately some of the people
are had to go home or head some of like
work-related things so this is part of
the team I don't know what to say
physically so thank you for coming and
see you next year probably and I'll
remember about about our meetups
we're having the x1 on the 28th of
November yes and yeah I would try to
keep keep it sequential every two months
so we see over there
thank you so much thank you team thanks
you